[Music]
it's the 1940s the world is at war and
for the first time in American history
women are joining the full-time
workforce in groves an organic chemist
by the name of hazel Bishop is in the
midst of designing aircraft fuel for
different oil companies but her true
interests lie elsewhere the influx of
women in the workforce hasn't changed
the superficial expectations of society
and working women are expected to look
well-groomed no matter their trade
Bishop is sick of having to take time to
powder her nose and reapply her lipstick
although the FDA has already begun
regulating cosmetics various ingredients
and lipsticks can be detrimental to
lapel the bromo acid stains used to
maintain color in most lipsticks are
terribly drying Bishop spends her spare
time working with stains and dyes mixing
oils and experimenting with molten wax
in a moment of vision and after years of
hard work
Bishop introduces one of the first
smudge-proof
long-lasting working women's lipsticks
that doesn't just tint the lips but also
keeps them healthy and moisturized
marketed as the only kissable lipstick
bishop's product takes off and it isn't
long before rival companies are not just
replicating the lipstick but creating
other more practical cosmetics today lip
cosmetics are a billion-dollar industry
[Music]
Oh
you